In the mood for a good laugh?
Well, you could always check out some big-budget
comedy everybody's seen a million times, or
you could dig a bit deeper and find something
funny that's been swept under the cinematic
rug.
If you want to try something a bit more obscure,
keep watching to discover some hysterical
comedies that flew completely under the radar.
After Hours
In 1985, legendary director Martin Scorsese
created one of the weirdest comedies to ever
come from a mainstream filmmaker, an oddball
movie called After Hours.
Griffin Dunne plays a guy named Paul Hackett
who just wants to get a ride home after a
date in New York City.
But instead, he finds himself lost in a twisted
Wizard of Oz universe version of the Big Apple
where everyone else seems to have gone completely
bonkers.
It all plays out like an eerily funny fever
dream or some long lost Lewis Carroll novel
where there are no rules and you should avoid
everyone you meet because they're all stark,
raving mad.
Withnail and I
Comedy isn't always just about the laughs.
For proof, look no further than 1987's Withnail
and I, a dark British comedy that reeks of
weed, wine, and desperation.
Paul McGann and Richard E. Grant play two
struggling actors who take a vacation in the
country to get their heads straight.
Filled with quotable lines and hilarious hijinks,
Withnail and I is also a deeply sad film about
struggling with addiction and finding yourself
trapped in life with nowhere to go but down.
Don't worry, though, it's still funny, with
Time Out London ranking it at number 7 on
its countdown of the 100 best comedies ever
made.
The Brothers Bloom
Rian Johnson is best known for films like
Brick, Looper, and Star Wars: The Last Jedi.
But he's also responsible for the criminally
underrated comedy The Brothers Bloom, a delightful
romp full of confidence schemes, double crosses,
and a lot of nitroglycerin.
Narrated by the great Ricky Jay, The Brothers
Bloom might be a bit too quirky for some,
but if you don't mind the fantastical style,
stars Mark Ruffalo, Adrien Brody, and Rachel
Weisz deliver performances that are incredibly
fun to watch.
Plus, like any good con movie, it does a great
job of constantly making you wonder if you're
in on the game or if you're actually being
played.
MacGruber
Inspired by the Saturday Night Live sketch,
MacGruber finds Will Forte sporting a mullet,
saving America, and finding weird new ways
to use celery sticks.
The film was a massive flop when it came out
in 2010 and was eviscerated by critics, but
in the years since, this send-up of 1980s
action flicks has found a cult following.
Even Christopher Nolan is a fan, telling Business
Insider there are scenes that had him "howling
uncontrollably."
Raunchy, bloody, and stupid in equal measures,
this one is simply classic MacGruber.
"Who's first?"
"Aw, s---!"
Tucker and Dale vs. Evil
If the horror genre has taught us anything,
it's that you can't trust a hillbilly.
It seems these backwoods bumpkins are always
looking for preppy kids to chop into tiny
pieces, right?
Well, 2010's Tucker and Dale vs. Evil flips
this idea on its head, turning the mountain
men into lovable lugs just trying to help
a group of vacationing college kids who are
so terrified by horror movie stereotypes about
rednecks that they keep accidentally killing
themselves.
Not only is Tucker and Dale vs. Evil hilarious,
it actually has an important message.
Good job, guys!
Everybody Wants Some!!
Directed by Richard Linklater, 2016's Everybody
Wants Some!! has been hailed as the "spiritual
sequel" to Linklater's classic Dazed and Confused.
Set in 1980, the film follows a group of college
baseball players in the days before class
starts.
There's not really much of a plot, as the
film focuses instead on the relationships
between these jocks, competitive dudes who
spend their days guzzling beer, battling each
other, and bonding over ball games.
It's extremely funny, while also examining
the mechanics of American masculinity.
"What am I thinking about?"
"Baseball…"
"Having a tail."
"Cereal?"
"F---!"
Hunt for the Wilderpeople
Before signing on to direct Thor: Ragnarok,
New Zealand native Taika Waititi gave us brilliant
gems like What We Do in the Shadows.
But the man really topped himself with 2016's
Hunt for the Wilderpeople, a story of two
misfits on the run from ninjas, dire wolves,
and an overzealous child welfare agent who
thinks she's the star of an American cop show.
Waititi's visuals are breathtaking, and the
film expertly jumps back and forth between
gut-busting comedy and tear-jerking sadness.
In short, this is one majestical movie.
"Once rejected.
Now accepted.
By me.
And Hector!
We're a trifecta!"
The Nice Guys
Written and directed by Shane Black, who redefined
the buddy cop film with Lethal Weapon, 2016's
The Nice Guys is one of the best entries in
the genre in recent memory, with stars Ryan
Gosling and Russell Crowe bouncing off each
other like bloody, boozy versions of Laurel
and Hardy.
Whether they're getting into gunfights, interrogating
witnesses, or discussing near-death experiences
involving Richard Nixon, Gosling and Crowe
make the perfect comedy team, and really,
we totally wouldn't mind seeing these actors
reunite somewhere down the line.
That would actually be pretty nice, guys.
Popstar: Never Stop Never Stopping
Straight from the incredible minds of The
Lonely Island, 2016's Popstar: Never Stop
Never Stopping attempts to do for pop music
what This Is Spinal Tap did for heavy metal.
And it succeeds, delivering a spot on, hilarious
mockumentary featuring Andy Samberg as a former
boy band star who finds success as a solo
act, only to learn being a loner isn't all
it's cracked up to be.
Jam-packed with some fantastically funny tunes,
it also features cameos from musicians like
Usher, Mariah Carey, and an amazing Justin
Timberlake.
"My name is Mr. Fish!"
"Yeah!"
"These guys thoughts have granted my wish!
Oh yeah!"
"All I wanna know is who's in that fish costume,
that was amazing!"
"The fish was me!"
By the time the credits roll, we guarantee
you'll want to jump out of your seat and start
doing the Donkey Roll.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!